house comras - Peter pack welcome to the
very organized thief it's the most
popular game on game Joel I think I'm
surprised I haven't played it before
probably because I have no [ __ ] clue
what it is I would guess that I'm a
thief so that's about it as much as far
as my intelligence stretches it does
look kind of spook see how did I break
in this is my house or someone else's
house Oh an iPhone great I was 101 now
you're a bush
oh here Elizabeth it's really burst I
try to make a joke and it went really
well
now let's never do that again okay so I
have a checklist all right so it's
making really Diego away TV um I'm go to
hell gold bar the home over statue has
to be some radio base bracelet got it
this is hard oh maybe I can cut the
electricity I don't know why I would do
that but maybe it will help in the
future who knows
Oh lawn mover take it I put it in my
breastesses keep searching don't tell me
what to do all right so we have one okay
oh no they're coming home
oh [ __ ] what is that [ __ ] noise is
there androids outside oh no I think
they came him oh no I better hurry up
stays what is Oh God
oh good no no they're coming in they're
gonna notice that I made the iPhone into
a pot which a blood oh my god he's cray
cray go away ah-ah-ah doc you beat me
you Pig that hurt wait what's the matter
with you hi Dawson
Oh ahh Wow now I understand so bad oh my
god oh I need random lies generator I
goddamn it that [ __ ] is slap the [ __ ]
out of me
so he noticed that [ __ ] was going on you
have to be a proper thief got it
why did I run the fridge
Teddy do we need still the teddy god
damn it two four nine five right two
four nine five oh okay cool green button
there we go give me all the cash do I
even need this I need the gold by now
Oh God
Oh God III made the alarm go reset nice
[ __ ] I'm in trouble they got two caps
probably bit ahead
I got him so [ __ ] why did I do that
I'm sure it's fine let's just be really
quiet to judge hi what am I supposed to
do bro I didn't know Europe Europe
you're a violator Taylor skater you know
that you have a problem gosh darn it you
know what I'm gonna take this I don't
even need this like me I'll break it
that's right [ __ ] I think we got it way
okay so I escaped with a lot of money
every day thief what and the best thief
ever what are you talking about gosh
darn it I think we have to do this again
all right let's do this one more time a
paint of an old lady I think that's this
one yeah yeah okay
it is it makes it easier when you at
least know some of them I guess
our God is coming home
okay let's do it you know what [ __ ]
Yolo he's gonna be so pissed
come on open ah [ __ ]
oh oh [ __ ] all right let's just [ __ ]
take all of it I'm rich [ __ ] what you
gonna do about it
I got all your money [ __ ] hahahaha oh
my god oh god oh god I could hear him
run oh my god what does that make me I'm
an organized thief Mike why thank you
hahaha that's I get a lot of fun I get I
get the gimmick I get ed guy no one
likes you no one why do you even try I
think I'm the only one who actually gets
scared playing this cake oh I need to
fix that all right I'm on my try baby I
can do this try hard appearance all
right I am a ninja god damn it Edgar I
am a very disorganized thief go away see
what you did you look I'm lotion Tom
here goddammit that crazy [ __ ] is gonna
beat my ass again I think I could beat
him though
I think he's me like who does that [ __ ]
when a burglar comes in their home huh
you know I'm saying I don't I don't even
check what I need any money this would
be a lot easier if I didn't just move
all this [ __ ] in his house rare wine oh
really how do I know I didn't even look
at it
that's red wine a man I don't even hate
to keep ID said this wine this wine is
the best wine maybe can I check the
garbage no [ __ ] you boy you are [ __ ]
garbage cried forever I don't know
that's the vase okay TV I need a TV I
put it in my ass along with it I need
you know your a hat go away
great hat oh you're not my surfing board
where do you go where do you go are they
what adventure watch oh there's the
silver oopsie I hope that wasn't more
red wine oh hello I'm rich don't care
no we don't need it [ __ ]
okay uh is there something there it's a
slice of toast
cinnamon Church Kennard sorry sir
underneath the platters here bet he
hides go away
Sam pie oh he's going through all the
rooms it's just a matter of time
oh god I'm a box he's never gonna find
this oh my god is that the teddy bear
that I needed hi hi man oh he didn't see
me is to visit jogging around the house
the box it works as perfect camouflage
don't mind me I'm just a flying box
you'll never find me you'll never see
the truth this game should be called a
very boxy box I need that I need that
awesome
actually helps it has a lights on now
all right boxes keep going do I need
that
do I need that I need that too oh my god
I'm on a roll baby
oh hey no I'm not I'm a box I'm a box
what is your why does he do it what are
you what are you doing oh he's crazy
what a weirdo that's your watch bro
that's he watch bro I don't [ __ ] what
the [ __ ] i subdued [ __ ] [ __ ] slaps
that's when I got goddamn Sam had a lamb
bama Ram wood tan
alright don't [ __ ] with the electricity
next time alright Chiklis stamp mobile
statue bicycle microwave bracelet
digital camera gold bar girl I really
want to finish this game
you know only he wasn't such a [ __ ] and
[ __ ] slap me you know open money money
money money money money a little bit all
right I need one more [ __ ] thing the
mobile phone where the [ __ ] is it
[ __ ] you [ __ ] pillow fight mother [ __ ]
up there's a spot ah
oh [ __ ] Teddy what are you doing Teddy
you cry cry
activate defense mechanism ah [ __ ] a
[ __ ] boxes all right he'll never find me
now [ __ ] what you gonna do oh [ __ ] he's
crazy
no don't subdue me don't subdue me
please nope nope box chairs what are you
doing no I subdued me oh so close
I want to do it [ __ ] [ __ ] one item a
toaster is going through making love to
that refrigerator some sexy [ __ ] man
this game is [ __ ] stressing with this
[ __ ] out man all right what if we have
jewelry box a gold bar so I'm just need
a jewelry box 1064 1064 jewelry box
might be in here of course it's not that
would be there it is 1064 1064 come on
baby
1:06 dick open up and take all this [ __ ]
take all the money
mmm that's all baby that table for me
girl ugly painting bring that too I can
escape there oh my god I'm rich [ __ ]
that's pretty good professional thief is
that better than very or that that's
probably better let's just look at that
I hope you bros enjoy this episode let
me know if you did leave 10 likes of
your bed you can't well ok 1 then hit
the sky Conroe today I'll see you Bruce
tomorrow love you red